ندوه حقوقيه نظمت في مدينه تعز المحاصره
سلطه الضوء على جرائم الميليشيات الحوثيه
واستعرضت تقريرا يبين طرق تحويل المساعدات
الامميه لدعم الحوثيين
[موسيقى]
الحوثي الطرق في حصارها لتعز هو اشبه بقطع
الشرايين المحافظه والذي يتسبب في موت
بطيء لخمسه ملايين نسمه في حصار دام
ثمانيه سنوات ترفض المليشيات وضع حد الله
الامر الذي تسبب في تعطيل تجديد الهدهد
الامميه مما يهدد مساعي السلام
الاوضاع الخنيقه في المحافظه ادت الى
تدهور الحاله الاقتصاديه وكانت سببا في
كارثه انسانيه
الحوثيه في ان تجعلها اكثر سوءا بقصف
الاحياء السكنيه وقتل المدنيين
سنوات من الحصار نتيجتها حوادث سير مميته
بسبب بعوره الطرق في مداخل تعز مما يزيد
الوضع الانساني ماساويه
اما استخدام الحوثيين للالغام التي يحرمها
القانون الدولي فما هو الا وجه اخر
لسداويه المخططات الحوثيه وما تحمله لليمن
واليمنيين من دمار وخراب العربيه